thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
I think I'm having a double chin kind of
day yeah
every time you do we all switched over
sir let me see we might hear me
what's going on
what's that playing what's that what's
up how you doing girl I'm doing good you
know what I'm saying I'm feeling good
you know it's a busy week you know a lot
going on you know kind of thing but I
just want to do some bike check seeking
some people in here real quick before we
move forward because you know the people
gonna let us know now that we had
switched over yo yo let's see what's
going on hopefully they can find us I
know they're gonna be like where the
hell is the last word at what's going on
this is not he bought us his channel
well
hahaha
so we gotta make sure that they find us
we're gonna make sure a person can find
us right now tweet that out yeah let's
get that tweet going out okay I'm gonna
say we're on a different Channel this
week yes yes that will be different it's
a professional podcasting
come joining us all right okay black
Iron Man I see you all right there we go
black Iron Man let me know man how the
levels is man is the levels okay are you
hearing me good Reginald Bowman what's
up man it's gonna be a while though yeah
you eat them messed up he didn't let the
kids run around the house right now we
unsupervised
and all that tension we've been having I
know now we can just let it go we can
let it out
cool just that real quick all right just
let me know how I'm sounding and how um
Trav is sounding
that would be very much appreciated sirs
but I see y'all in there and Trav give
some Mike checks man talk to people
hello
my name is Travis and I have strong
opinions about Destiny nice nice no one
agrees with me
thus carry it was going on Lincoln kicks
that sounds good okay okay I need y'all
to let me know Trav sounds good oh y'all
okay both y'all sounded good that's what
I need all right now I feel good
appreciate y'all appreciate y'all thank
you for coming everybody's kind of
spread the word I know it's kind of a
little different scenario he's on vacay
but uh we're gonna get this thing
started man Trevor you ready to rock
I'm ready to smooth jazz
you're getting ready to ride he smooth
jazz not ready to rock I'm ready to
smooth jazz smooth jazz it is all right
my speed and we are live the last word
with Laura Cognito no cheetah and my man
Thai Guy Travis fresh on that Thursday
evening campfire let's get to it first
of all how are you doing sir what's been
going on with you is a lot going on with
IGN and a lot going on with you with
reviews what's going on with you man
yeah man I mean first off I just want to
say we did it guys we got rid of the
worst part of the show and
um we're gonna have a great episode
don't do both
we love you e
well-deserved rest man that man works
hard rarely goes on vacation so it's
good to have that man get some rest and
he actually was he has scheduled videos
and I think in his scheduled videos he
someone put like you're lazy man
on vacation he tweeted put out a video
scheduled every day and still get caught
lazy yeah sad face to be fair
true and uh
personally if I were to take a break
which I wouldn't because that's insane
but if I did
I would not go on a cruise that doesn't
sound like a time off to me okay you got
a cruise kind of guy not a cruise kind
of guy
but you know what I look at ebontist and
I think there's a man who belongs on a
cruise ship oh my God they should keep
him he could just be one of those at Sea
people no social security number no
birth certificate just are those still a
thing are there people who want to see
and don't live anywhere wow
no I'm just kidding uh so yeah what am I
up to
um some stuff I can't talk about
unfortunately yet but I'm doing some
cool projects and reveals and then
um the main thing I've been working on
is my Dead Island 2 review which is
going to be live on Tuesday Morning
um I already finished the game a long
time ago it's it's been in the bag for a
while but it's one of those things I
haven't been able to talk about so
um I'll be able to talk about that in a
little bit and other than that you just
keeping busy man doing some yeah it's
like I'm working on like five things
right now and most of them I can't talk
about I can't talk about and this is
Destiny related is
um somebody asked me
uh to make a guide for
um free to play players in Destiny oh
nice which is interesting so what I had
to do to accomplish this because it's
really hard to understand the
proofreadable play experiences I created
a new account uh from Destiny I did like
the two hour shahan intro oh yeah I
actually hadn't done those in a while
and two things stuck out to me one
um aside from the middle part where
you're just doing random crap I think
that just to explain mechanics the intro
quests are actually pretty cool there's
like the the OG intro one which still
has a special place in my heart and then
there's the uh the quest where you first
commune with the traveler which right
now by the way super awkward because you
pray to the traveler and the Traveler's
not there and then uh yeah it's super
weird and then uh you finish up the
storyline and then you go to the Tower
and when you go to the Tower
crazy you have to get your ship from you
know you have to register with the tower
from Amanda holiday who's still there yo
yo I'll text them all it is
all it is there and then you go and you
talk to Zavala which is also I mean
she's still in the game but it's also
just weird yeah and then and then while
you're talking to Zavala The Traveler is
still there right in front of you and
then yeah it's still like the traveler
has not left Earth yet it's like still
right there in front of you I did this
today so it's like fresh in my mind and
then when you're done with uh with you
do a strike you do the strike where you
kill
um who's the consort of uh crota the
um
or whatever no no no the other one oh
yeah yeah yeah Destiny one yeah yeah
what's your name the screen mode the one
that you want in the sack
what is her name which that is like
notorious
chat help us I've only done this strike
90 zillion times there was so many
cheeses for it now we'll figure because
what it is they changed her name yeah
and they updated it found something else
it's something else no it's not Nevada
how dare you no the original name what
was the original name yeah what was the
original name Chad I'm the goal I'm the
goal there we go
I knew somebody would know it uh so you
go and you do the strike against omnigol
and that that officially kind of ends
the shahan arc okay and then it plays
another cut scene where it it actually
and I didn't know this was in the game
it plays a separate cutscene that's new
to lightfall and it explains all of the
brief summary of the fact that the
darkness is coming it shows the witness
and then it shows uh The Traveler
leaving Earth uh and going into outer
space and then it stops the story there
and then uh it says present day on the
screen I actually recorded this because
I saw it and I was like I've never I've
never seen I didn't even know this was
in the game so I recorded it um and then
it loads you into the tower again and
then when you get to the Tower that time
it's up to date like the Traveler's gone
and you know all the stuff that's
changed has changed
um but uh what's interesting is what's
interesting when you come back from that
strike and it tries to load you into the
new tower the game crashes
the darkness
this is him crash
es um and I did it on two separate
accounts and both times the game crashes
and it put it either puts you in an
infinite loading screen or just the app
blows out and then you have to go back
into the app load back into the game and
then when you do you're in a new
Tower instance so that's the only way I
could find a solve it was just to start
the game over but it seems like they
just they haven't fixed this bug where
the game just always crashes if you
create a new account yeah so it's funny
you say that because um you know for me
what's been knowing at me as a person
who loves something like Destiny's my
heart one thing that always bugged me
was like I didn't get the what is it now
1250 achievements so it's funny that
you're going back for for the reason of
a new black experience I went back last
week for the whole point of all right
I gotta get remember I'm a one character
guy so I never got the achievement that
said acquire all the Titan subclasses
and try all the hunters of classes
because I warlock all day so now I'm
like you know what it's easier than ever
to do it now right and get the get the
thing so what I did is again they put
you through the new line experience but
now it's like to get the other subclass
it's very simple it's like shoot avoid
weapon and create orbs you know to get
the void subclass shoot so I'm like oh
this is so easy but here's the thing I
did all this and bro the achievements
did not pop
I'm freaking I'm like I did all of this
so I literally had to go on to like
Reddit and as a message board and the
fix was Lord log in with the character
switch back and forth to kind of like
remind the game this is you have it you
have it you have it and then it pops
so now I am officially 1250 gamer score
or destiny I have every achievement
because it was bothered about my soul
bro that I didn't have all the
achievements so that was about all the
achievements in D1 yeah all achieve is a
D1 and then because the the hardest rate
yeah but I cheat but we know crota come
on Crow this dude where you do that at I
didn't do it I didn't do it that way
would you get Flawless King's fall oh
you're a big salute warlock what
happened was the king's fall was uh we
were doing it every week with this group
and for a lot of them were East Coast so
I would wake up at five in the morning
to do this I would do the raid and it
would take us like 90 minutes and then I
would go to work like immediately after
and so uh we just started doing it every
week we'd wake up on Tuesdays at five
a.m and we'd just like run it
was it 5 a.m on Tuesdays it must have
been because it was so early but I don't
remember when reset was back then and
maybe it was on a Wednesday but yeah we
do it every weekend and one morning we
did it and we were just talking comchat
we did zero comms we were just like on
autopilot and it popped and we were all
like
wow that's crazy man I salute you so
you've been doing all that you did going
back you're doing new life experience
reviewing games all that any any uh
Banner this week or just you've been so
caught up with everything else that this
week was kind of light for you yesterday
oh iron Banner
although I I it's still open right for
the weekend no no it's done now I think
Charles comes back uh this weekend so
okay so for me yeah busy week is it's
been crazy I'm sorry if you if you more
stuff he was doing on no no that's fine
yeah man it's been it's been a busy week
for me obviously so much going on you
know that all the news and then the
final Duke and then it's the travel and
work and you gotta gotta but gaming wise
I fired up ghost wide to Tokyo because I
waited for it to um come in I actually
like it I actually like it you know
performance aside there's some
performance issues that uh you know
definitely need a dressing for my OLED
gang I would highly put it on the high
frame rate mode with vsync that made it
way smoother and it I really enjoyed the
movement but it's a unique game I like
the hand movements as far as the
fighting and stuff like that and the
verticality of the game is really cool
so I'm gonna stick with it it's this
real you know weird thing when it's like
Spirit kind of embodies the person who
died and you have this relationship with
this spirit yeah I played it yeah it's
it's weird but it's keeping me in for
some reason so I want to see where that
goes I've been rocking that still been
doing all Tango's games all Tango's
games are super weird but they're
nothing good uh goes to our Tokyo I
didn't finish because it kind of gets a
little repetitive okay at least it was
when I played it but maybe it's a
different game now but uh I really like
Tango super underrated death I like I
like Tango a lot too I like I I just
love the fact that Xbox kind of has a
Japanese Studio by proxy kind of thing
but yeah it's really cool so I've been
rocking that I've still been doing my
little Seafood but I did play a lot of
Destiny I did play you know I jumped in
Banner a lot last week we got uh did a
root of nightmares run
um I got um I finally got the linear
solo Fusion I got a terrible roll but
it's because what I realized now
aggressive linears are really good like
remember how they nurse what happened
ryers yeah right yes yes because
remember how they Nerf Taipan
everybody's like oh that's it it was a
good run
aggressives y'all aggressives are really
good so I've been rocking that um got a
better role on rufus's the auto rifle so
I've been rocking that but uh yeah it's
been it's been it's still been a lot
I've been working a lot with my solar
build and stuff like that so I've been
rocking but yeah man let's get to it I
know there's a lot of stuff also what's
up gotta Breyers this week what you got
what role you got what you got I got
reconstruction and frenzy oh
okay okay okay yeah not it's not a god
rule but like I'll take it and then I'm
just gonna every week do the get the red
border on that until I can craft it you
know so yeah finally replaced my storm
chaser finally oh yes the whole Chase is
so good too yeah I love love Stone chick
I gotta get a good roll on that Briars
though man I really love that linear
just so I can free up the heavy slot and
just get the red borders just grind it
out you know what I mean yeah you're
right I gotta I gotta get in there more
it's you know what it is about that
radio Travis like I like it but there's
a huge portion of the raid that's just
travel
but you don't feel so true that's fair
like a lot of travel between encounters
to extend the length of the rake out of
a deal and uh I'm curious speaking of
flawless Raider do you think
do you think it would be an issue with
the whole lightness Darkness or switch
it back where it blows up on you that
kind of thing as far as like if you you
think you could get it with a team but
the Flawless Raider with that raid with
that travel mechanic oh the shooting
across yeah and I don't really have
trouble with the shooting across but I
play Titan I feel like Titans are maybe
the best Equip to do
by far the worst because like if you tap
a at the wrong time you start to float
down like aggressively
yeah like for warlocks like that that
little
shoot is just it's it's awful bro it's
so inconsistent that's what's
frustrating about it but yeah for Titans
but I was just wondering like maybe get
a crew with Titans you think you could
do it you could Flawless that thing
without any I don't know glitches no is
there a reason to
yeah I think there may be some uh
triumphs and stuff attached to it you
know what's going on shout out to
outstanding he said Kyle did you do the
massive challenges I did not I did not I
know Grandmaster also popped off this
week I don't know if any even attempt
that Madness
yeah I'm not but I don't even think I'm
a high enough level to do it what is the
18 15. yeah something like that and then
I think it is double rewards week this
week and it is I believe scalable but
we'll see but anyway shouted back for
dead he said he'll take reconstruction
frenzy over his slide shots surrounded
that's I guess he's talking about his um
what you call it the uh rufuses no doubt
but uh yeah man oh shout out to send us
those I'll see you in there bro but yeah
we got to get into this tour man it's
been a
spicy bunch of developments I've been
seeing Twitter shout out to cool guy you
know a lot a lot of talk about
accessibility do we preface this with
the fact that usually ebonta says our
twab pre-reader and neither of us have
read it yes we're just gonna kind of go
in and raw and what do you call it
uncensored we're doing it wrong y'all
we're doing it wrong we're doing it
wrong
safety guards here no safety gunlist you
guys sometimes you got to go and roll
when the cheat is away
I can't say I can't we gonna be too
loose today here
he ain't gonna like this he ain't gonna
upload this on his channel
it's a little loose if you're trying to
go in raw you know what I mean listen
situations call for situation
anyway this week at Bungie y'all so uh
look they they talked about um things
they talked about last week what they
reflected on lightfall prep for the
Grand Master night falls they um shared
our weapons and I leave it at the end of
season 20 and they're on the way for 21
and they talked about prime rewards they
got cut seem happy so this week it's
more about third party peripheral usage
drasticity
um they want to commend you for having
that that drip
um reminder about trials Labs I'm gonna
leave that section for you I want you to
read that section when you get to trials
last I want your raw emotions on that
one
um Bungie Foundation is getting kill
happy update to known last known issues
and then obviously the weekly movie of
the week and all that good stuff so
let's get to the the Hot Topic right now
which is third party peripherals
entering the Bungie's entering their
villain Arc they say their Community has
grown increasingly frustrated by a form
of cheating that uses third-party
peripherals with the intent to
manipulate the game client these devices
are plugged into a computer console
where they can in for example execute
simple scripts or trick the game into
giving you extra aim assist you'll note
that we aren't calling out their
services by name Zim
you know the other one but we're gonna
leave it alone the primary reason for
that acronyms I believe is that we we
simply don't want to offer a bigger
Spotlight than necessary instead our
focus on what the impact of using tools
like this has on a PVP environment to
this end Bungie has adapted the
following policy on any form of external
AIDS okay so again One external
accessibility AIDS or any device or
input that augments the player's ability
to control the game beyond what the game
itself normally provides this includes
but it's not limited to programmable
controllers keyboard and mouse adapters
Advanced macros or automation via
article artificial intelligence this
does not include features that Bungie
provides and they're going to talk about
more have a link as far as well the
stuff that they use for accessibility
number two experience the game designers
intended means that content meant to be
difficult or Prestige is designed like
that for a reason we do not intend for
difficult to be ordered automated via
software Hardware therefore simply using
an accessibility Aid to play Destiny 2
where a player could not play otherwise
would not be a violation of this policy
using these tools to mitigate challenges
all players face such as reducing recoil
or increasing aim assist would be a
violation and then the final part of
this villain Arc as far as third party
peripherals gain an advantage means use
for the purpose directly or indirectly
of achieving victory for example some
players that abuse these tools rise in
the PvP rank Stratus at a rate far
beyond what is expected for a player
through normal typical play because of
the benefits of cheating in PVE kind of
because the benefits of cheating in PVE
could affect things like the world's
first race or even spill into PVP we
will be evaluating all gameplay for
violations they're going to be issuing
warnings restrictions or bans
appropriately this has been a matter of
extended conversations internally in the
community they want to strike the right
balance between Bungie's goal of
simultaneously enabling everyone and
protecting the community this is on fire
right now especially some key statement
I mean now that we're doing this Raw
what's your initial feelings what's your
initial thoughts about this
uh it sounds good
um yeah I I feel like it's going to be a
hard line to walk between
uh letting people play their game using
third party peripherals because as soon
as you open that Floodgate it's kind of
hard to shut it and control it and
people always find work around so it's a
challenging thing I'm glad they're
taking it on
I'm interested about some of this
because I know nothing about the world
of cheating that's I mean that's why I
don't play on PC
uh and uh
but it is interesting to see some of the
stuff they're dealing with having AI
play Destiny for you I think you really
have a problem when you're building
automation to play video games that to
me seems like we've lost the way at that
point you're not even playing your games
yourself that you have to get a robot to
do that too
it's not the dishes you know what I mean
like you can have a robot do the dishes
I get that but having it play your video
game for you seems it seems Seems a lot
crazy seems a lot yeah yeah I also
wanted to uh bring the attention one
thing shout out to my main cool guy who
he actually brought issue with the
sentence when they said uh Bungie
Embraces the use of external
accessibility AIDs that enable and
experience the gaming game desires that
is intended but will take action
including bands or people who abuse the
tools specifically to gain an advantage
so he goes uh how does one take action
with those sentences back to back it's
like you can't embrace the use of
external accessibility AIDS and then
also say that if you use these external
aids to specifically gated advantage
that's a No-No is is it or is it not it
sounds like what they're saying is
um
if you wouldn't be able to play the game
otherwise and you need that device then
you can use it but if you're a
completely abled player who uses it
because it says who wouldn't be able to
play otherwise in that first clause and
I think that's the important part like
if you're just like a abled person using
a you know Xbox adaptive controller
connected to your PC so that you can you
know auto aim or avoid recoil then I
think that's where they're going to draw
the line so I think the way I'm reading
this is they're stepping away from their
usual policy of if it's an exploit you
can do it which has always been their
policy in Destiny right like like as
long as you're not modifying the game
you can do exploits but it sounds like
they're saying no no this one if you
exploit it we and we find out we will
ban you um let me push back what about
the person who says
I I'm I have a a disability you mean the
uh the emotional support animal argument
that I constantly have to deal with in
California yes yes I'm very familiar
with this as somebody who constantly is
annoyed by dogs inside restaurants and
crap and clearly they're not they don't
need this animal I don't even believe
emotional support animals are a real
thing to be honest with you I think
everybody's but I feel bad if you have
those clears and I don't I should have
what you have and I need this I need
this support
yeah
um I mean it's up to Bungie to walk that
line yeah right I think if they're
probably seeing like streamers just like
blow through trials using uh third party
peripheral you know I think that they're
probably going to take action on stuff
like that but
I mean unless they know who you are they
can't prove that you don't yeah or do
you need a device and so you'll probably
be able to use it if you have anonymity
but I also don't know what tools they
have in play for this this is kind of a
blind spot for me because yeah I I avoid
the PC console platform specifically
because I hate all the stuff right
we have some people like Teddy who I
think part of the reason he likes the PC
consoles because he can build like a a
bot to tell him to go run strikes for
him to move him every five minutes so he
doesn't get AFK while he's making other
people do work yo remember that and
Gambit when people were so sick of
Gambit they would just log in and they
would just you would just see the moon
I remember that yo when I was on PC
thank you for inviting me deep so yeah I
I don't really know a ton about this or
how they would monitor it but I get what
they're saying so you're saying hey we
want to be accessible but also doing
that is going to open up the floodgates
and we're gonna fight back against it
which I personally I think that's the
right decision I don't think you want to
say well because we're so Pro
accessibility we're going to allow
perfectly able people to just game the
system
um you know because that's like
bringing your dog into a movie theater
because you need the emotional support
or parking in a handicap spot you know
it's not it's not the right thing to do
you could do it it's not the right thing
that's the right thing to do okay I see
where we go let's get some super chess
shout out to Lord Metroid two out Super
Chat hey Cog just one month tears of the
Kingdom big big links outside laugh out
loud salute they're giving me crap
because the new trailer came out and the
last what I wasn't that impressed when
this one was actually pretty good I did
like this this latest one but you know
we'll see let's see another Super Chat
neck romances Zale two dollars of a chat
ban them ASAP oh he went to bed okay he
not he not playing with okay cool I
wanted to ask you this because I see my
man sent us in the chat about aimbots
and stuff like that like with your
experience with trials
if you had to put a percentage
say now like how do you feel like you're
in that 1v1 duel you're like nah bro you
know I mean that shot was too good like
like how often do you feel you had to
put a percentage when you're in high
level play in PvP that you feel that
you've been cheated on
zero percent okay yeah but I also play
on Console right it's harder to do it
and I don't I don't typically cross play
with PC players in PvP if I can avoid it
yeah
um for that reason uh and also I don't
believe a computer could beat me I just
don't I'm sorry I I'm not saying a
computer could never beat me but the
computers we have now if Bungie can't
program the AI to be better no game
developer in the industry think about
this Cog
Ai and games peaked with Halo Combat
Evolved they've not gotten better so if
they couldn't program better AI across
the industry for you know for for 20
years I really doubt that some you know
third-party app is going to be able to
make a robot that can be like competent
players I get you on the full AI you
know automation like when we play Halo
with it and number you know the Box we
give her those boxes yeah exactly
there's no way exactly yeah what I'm
talking about is the guys who are lining
up to get the perfect headshot that it
with some weapons that are high skill
weapons or you know you're in the middle
of a thing turn around no scope bam and
you're like whoa now to your point I
don't feel like I encountered a lot on
Console much either but they're off like
maybe if I had to put a percentage I
would say like I feel like
10 to 20 percent there's a couple of
ones I'm like not what was questionable
but for the most part my experience does
Feel clean and sometimes when I lose up
like that I was good I got outplayed or
I stayed in that too long that
engagement that kind of a thing but
there were once I would say every out of
it every 10 matches maybe you know two
I'll be like I don't know about you with
this one but I'ma let that slide but
that's how I feel yeah I don't know
maybe I I'm not very reflective on that
sort of stuff I'm just sort of like
looking ahead when I get killed I'm just
like look he killed me he can't change
it but I'm explaining about it I don't
encounter it so often that I think it's
because I I play with people like if
somebody does something crazy and shoots
me most of the time I'll be like
oh damn yeah yeah that's good yeah
that's good but sometimes like I it has
happened before obviously like
um especially before they got better at
detecting cheaters and when I was
playing on PC uh I would see you know
some guy snipe me through a wall and be
like all right there's no way like it
wasn't it wasn't like he was close to
the wall and he was peeking is like he's
on the other side of the damn you know
level and he Skype me and I'll be like
all right that wasn't real
more people resurrecting themselves I've
seen that yes
that one actually I see kind of often
yeah not not on consoles too much but
when I was on PC I would see that all
the time they auto-res themselves with
like a button and I was like damn I
didn't know they added self-res back
this is crazy yeah it's it's nuts man I
I remember that that era was crazy but I
think for me I just overall quickly on
my thoughts on it you know I've heard
the names Zim Cronus I have heard them
you know I do think this is like you
said primarily the PC community and
things that they have been dealing with
you know not saying that console is
perfect but I I think that um it's
lesser than one of the reasons why I was
so excited when series consoles came out
I can play at 60 but um it is
interesting this stance I think about
the um how how aggressive they they're
getting now and I'm just curious what
the data showed to to kind of prompt
this this reaction now so the vibe I'm
getting maybe there's an uptick and that
they think okay we you got to put the
hammer down on this but at the same time
be clear of people who have
accessibility issues so I just think my
only concern is just the time
accessibility third-party tools is new
isn't it yes wasn't that a thing they
added this season so it might just be it
created new problems or maybe this was
always part of the plan because they
knew it was going to open the floodgates
it could be something like that but yeah
it is interesting um I think they're
making the right calls though yeah you
ban people you can if they're if they're
abusing the system and then you let go
what you have to let go yeah no that's
fair enough and then we got into the
next portion which is uh it's for me
walk walk fashion baby the dress to
these section so the uh shout out to the
player identity team that's what they
call them right now they said let's talk
trip so high Guardians back when we're
first developing combinations we had a
sneaky suspicion that a fashion Focus
combination would be highly desired as
we continued into long-form play testing
the knee became even more obvious but by
then we were past the point of editing
anything new to season 20 and we could
only tweak into what we already had so
they have the little card they got the
little crown with the with the helmet on
it little logo looks kind of cool
um but once life all launched we saw the
feedback over again I want a Best
Dressed combination or I'm just giving
the combination to the teammate with the
best outfit and so on so because we love
our fashion Community we dug in and
moved it up to the season 20 mid-season
patch now best dress isn't going to have
a large Commendation score but fashion
is never about getting to high school
just the most Accolade so best dress
also are restricted to what we call low
trust activities so max man activities
that don't rely on significant
communication on TV you know that's
Travis's favorite
not trials
not trials raids or dungeons now it's
trials you don't want to get that best
how are you going to allow people to
solo queue in trials and then say that
it's a mode that requires communication
like you changed it so that it is no
longer one of those modes so it should
be in there sure did that's what they
said so they said if you think your clan
bait is the best dress you can just tell
them this isn't a high school Award Best
dress is about giving a stranger a
compliment so I'm gonna jump in clearly
this is one of the major reasons why I
love I'm not even gonna lie this is one
of the major reasons why I love Destiny
I'm not even gonna lie I am I am the guy
right now that's in the forums like look
you guys put in the loadouts
but here's my problem here's my problem
punching here I'll talk to y'all yes I
can switch my subclasses yes I can name
how come when I change to my Loadout my
emblem for my avoid class isn't there my
ship and my sparrow that matches
accordingly my my purple and black void
drip but I'm doing void lock see now
you're halfway there so we gotta we got
to work on this but we're gonna Embrace
dressing we got to go all the way with
it so this is for me traffic this right
here this little card I I would have
take pride in having the highest dress
score in the in the community because I
know my drip is nice man I got I got
every subclass every situation tell you
it's real mean out here so I embrace
them representing my community right now
they doing a good thing they're on the
right path but for you you know I know
you're wearing them Walmart blues and
stuff out there how you out there
how's your dress game these days sir
yeah I don't care
um I don't care I I mean I don't look
terrible but I put about like five
seconds of thought and usually I'll just
like
I'll take uh whatever the most recent
cool armor set is and I'll apply it
universally and then I'll find a Shader
that works and I'll apply it universally
yeah you look good all right we did
cakes before I checked you out
I was like now yeah yeah he doing all
right yeah the one I might go to is I
really like the iron Banner armor where
you look like a samurai I think that is
the best Titan armor so I throw that on
there and then I use uh the iron wood uh
um Shader and it just makes me look like
um you know um
yeah I uh yeah I roll with that usually
but I have like a couple like biggest
hits the one I've been doing now is the
cowboy outfit because I think it's funny
I look like a cowboy guy but uh uh yeah
um to me this isn't the thing I love
about Destiny but I understand a lot of
people love it usually bad people like
Paul Tassie oh dare uh but um there are
people technically it was a game that
they enjoy so what about the emblem
though you don't care about the emblem
to match the outfit and the ship the
sparrow the emblem show up ever well we
get all bit you gotta so you could Flex
because that emblem sometimes you get
them rare problems that you only get
from certain activities is a flex
I'll do it when people are showing off
their emblems and acting like they're
cool okay and then I feel I feel like I
have to like rain on the parade so then
I'll pick out one that I like know they
don't have like uh the uh the the movie
of the week okay the weekend okay I'll
just like slap that thing on and be like
yeah and you guys got this yeah I didn't
think so let me tell you how Petty I am
you know I don't go to the lighthouse
bro when I got that flawless I could not
take that thing off bro I was letting
everybody know that that goal with the
black and the stuff bro I made a whole
outfit I got the the dawn of chorus with
that bronze gold now I got the ship
everything is golden with me that's the
level I ever said I gotta let people
know traffic that's what it's about you
gotta show off though you got to let
people know that they are not on your
level especially you with your your
accolades remember that time uh Kanye
West said billionaires don't wear their
chains
I gotta do too but
that's a good one Chad you ain't had to
go there you ain't had to go there
salute salute so salute to salute the
bungee for looking out for us for petty
people you know so guys I'm glad you're
getting some stuff you want I will I
will be sure to give you this Accolade
and we know you don't deserve any other
ones
are you getting this you know what I
mean don't worry about me not going to
the correct play in The King's fall raid
don't worry about it you know Travis
like your [__] no no this you got to be
over
I was a little distracted well make sure
I get all focused when we're doing our
King's full run but I wanted to get this
section I need you to read this this is
the big one trials lab show and I have
not read this this is raw
so the labs the trial labs
just as a reminder we will have two more
trials Labs on week 8 and 11 of season
20. in both we'll be testing the new
matchmaking parameters to gather
analytics and verify they work as
intended on a large scale for a
refresher on how the new matchmaking
works from the dev team
we will now have two always active soft
pools
soft means that matchmaking initially
prefers not to blend the pools but will
if necessary to find a good game quickly
so the distinction is not as dramatic as
the one between Flawless and
non-flawless in the current system
okay and then they're going to tell us
what the two pools are okay because that
was my next question one is Challenger
pool this is where most players who
currently play trials on a week-to-week
basis and who want to go Flawless will
play it represents an experience more
like the original iteration of trials in
D1 without the focus on making games
more difficult as the card progresses or
after you've been flawless
is that true trials in D1 didn't focus
on making the game more difficult as
your card progressed
I think I think if I remember it was
more focused on the ones who had the
same wins as you at the current state of
the card yeah that's what that's what
they're saying without the focus on
making games more difficult as the card
progresses but I feel like I mean I I
feel like every you always know games
five six and seven are super sweaty yes
I remember okay well okay I don't know
about that but anyway that's what
they're saying they're claiming that it
wasn't like that in D1 and that this is
also not gonna be like that
the Challenger pool matches or based
solely on a connection there's no
matchmaking based on tickets wins on
tickets wins weekly wins or skills
that's terrible oh okay okay great and
then players who have any card with no
losses including card after reset or
those playing with someone on their fire
team that has a card with no losses will
be placed in this pool
interesting
are those
playing with someone in the far team
that has a car with no losses
interesting okay this is weird
um this seems like a change and it
sounds like they're going into pure
chaos as the trials mode rather than it
being based on
tournament style ticket progression
um
interesting and we got practice pool
and then we've got the practice pool
this pool is a tar is targeted at new or
less experienced players players who are
not yet ready to give go and follow us a
shot and represents a place for them to
dip their toes into trials without being
thrown straight into the deep end this
pool matches based on connection and
weekly performance how well you've done
in Trials this week and it resets every
week only players with a Flawless with a
flawed card or those on their first game
of the week can play in this pool
everyone in your fire team must have a
flawed card or be on their first game of
the week
this pool has stomp protection if you
are consistently struggling it will
reduce your weekly performance rating to
give you slightly easier matches until
you recover and it has farming
protection the system detects that you
or fire team member are likely
attempting to farm the practice pool
that will slow down your matchmaking
times initially and if you continue it
will lock you into the Challenger pool
for the remainder of the weekend
regardless of your card State there this
is very odd is what I have to say
very odd and so this is part of my
problem with where trials has been
lately
and I'm glad people are having fun with
it uh that said trials to me feels like
it has no identity and I say that
meaning it it basically is a slightly
different game mode to you know regular
elimination or other modes that you're
playing uh and it doesn't have much to
it that makes it feel unique or makes me
feel excited about it okay
um the fact that it no longer is a game
that you have to play with a group of
three people is probably the notable
biggest change now you can just jump in
matchmaking
and now apparently they're taking out
the part that makes it feel like a
tournament where your wins and progress
on your card are part of what makes up
the pool so to me it just seems like
a
pool party
where you know
show up whole bunch of different types
of people and you're just kind of
hanging out having fun and hopefully you
you know go Flawless if you're lucky and
if you don't then then that's fine too
um but yeah just I don't I just from
reading this the thing that stuck out to
me was wow trials really doesn't have
like a goal like there's no kind of like
stated Mission behind like play trials
this is the idea of Trials you know how
like Gambit sucks but at least Gambit
has a goal right it's like oh what if we
mixed PVE and PVP and made this kind of
interesting you can invade World trials
to me like if you ask me to describe it
I don't even know where I'd begin I'd be
like it's a kind of a tournament but you
don't really go fight against people who
are in the bracket you don't Advance
down a bracket uh oh and you also don't
have to play with the dedicated team you
can just run in and match make and like
the farther you explain it the more the
person that you were explaining it too
would go that doesn't sound like a
tournament and you're like yeah it's not
I actually don't know what it is like
that's where I would kind of end up so
like the messaging it sort of bothers me
yeah the message the message is lost I'm
not really sure what trials is supposed
to be or who it's supposed to be for and
it sounds like based on pools that
they're trying to make everybody happy
by adding a practice pool and a
challenger pool and I
don't I think probably my guess is that
it's going to end up making nobody happy
because it doesn't have any identity and
and focus it's lost Focus it's my
promise it is interesting because you
know for me
you know recently it's been kind of like
some of my most fun with trials but I
it's not obviously I went to the
lighthouse yes but the the reality is I
felt the matchmaking was actually good
in my case like I felt like you know
jumping in Solo I I felt that there were
people of equal skill level to me and
yes you know there were some people that
were on the opposite team that were
better you know I mean I know I played
well as a team I know I did I was
implying applying tactics that really
was improving my game but at the same
time you know there were times where
there were some beasts on the other side
and I had to respect it so I felt like
yo it was getting to a nice place so now
we get to this system when we have to
act we're going to create two active
soft pools so the question becomes you
know when we fire up the director
there's there's I'm assuming there's
going to be two nodes Challenge and and
thing my I guess my curiosity is for the
challenge it sounds like there's not
going to be two nodes because they're
soft pools softball is correctly you
click on one button and then it's going
to decide which one you are because they
are very specific prescriptions for how
you get in both which is why I think
their last bullet was about farming
protections yes if you tell people how
to get into the pool they're going to
get into it if they feel it's more
beneficial so it's good that they wrote
that there I'll be interested to see how
that goes for them yeah you're right
because it says if the system detects
that you or a farmer fire team member
are likely attempting to farm but see if
they say likely attempting to farm the
practice pool does that not scream
something that's visible or no
um it might be like if you're winning
every single game in the practice pool
and the only loss you got was your first
one on your ticket just so that you
could get in there oh I see what you're
saying the guy that oh yes yes the guy
that'll reset you might just lose one
match okay as soon as you do you're like
all right now I'm just gonna yeah yeah
yeah yeah you're right you're right
because that's that dude that'll do that
to his card you're right yeah I think
that's it I think that's it so I guess
my only issue my concern is the the
Challenger pool because
you know like you said to me the spirit
of Trials is that seven wins that
flawless the sentence that bothers me is
this pool matches Challenger pool this
pool match is based solely on connection
there is no matchmaking based on tickets
wins on tickets weekly wins or skill
so if this is quote unquote the
Challenger right this is the sweaty this
is what we we here for
didn't and that is interesting to me
it's solely based on connection
and the matchmaking is based on tickets
there is no matchmaking so there's no
matchmaking I would understand if if the
preference was connection or that was
the first criteria or something like
that but it sounds like based on this
language like the answer is it's only
connection yeah looking at anything else
this time which seems crazy but we still
have to assume that a three-win ticket a
five win ticket is going to match up
against another five minute ticket
otherwise it would be trial but the the
outside of that criteria the matchmaking
will just be primarily focused on
connection is basically what I'm getting
am I reading that right
such a weird sentence that sentence is
the one I'm struggling with let me see
what the chat said because I out of for
some reason I'm like all over the place
on that sentence yeah you're in one was
connection no Flawless shout out to e oh
man yeah I love you easy this everybody
just oh he's just there from vacation I
had to stop at home yet bro love you bro
enjoy vacation you gotta help oh oh this
is helping us look at the Yvonne look at
them posted from from the cruise he said
it's just one node oh man so yeah just
one note so e see that she there what do
you think about that sentence you know
where they where they specifically say
you know
that is solely on Connection in
reference to the um the not prioritizing
the wins the weekly wins and whatever
that that sentence was just very very
interesting to me let me see if I'm
actually going to see if I can
do a little professional podcasting for
what's and uh share screen and see if I
can do that in the middle oh this would
be fun yeah I've done a screen sharing
yeah I haven't done that in eons but
we're going to try it we're gonna try so
uh
this week yeah yeah all right let's get
a [__] going
oh all right hopefully you people can
see this is the sentence y'all that is
really really getting me right here
which is this
I need to chat to let me know man you
don't say what y'all think about that
chat like what what do y'all get out of
that the charger pool just pull pull
matches solely on connection there is no
matchmaking based on tickets wins on
tickets wins weekly wins or skill what
do y'all get out of that I need I need
some energy would I get out of that is
damn we need dedicated servers real bad
that's what I get out of that
okay all y'all see is Osiris oh no
stop the [__]
oh well there goes that professional
podcast
we'll figure it out later but um yeah
that was that was really it man that
that was the part that we're a little
confused about but I want to chat y'all
to jump in there okay regimen I like the
idea Flawless pool and there was weekend
that they did that how many wins you get
is how you match up what was missing
with rewards and cosmetics fair enough
fair enough
um he act he loves it he said I love
that gives everyone a chance to go
Flawless trap oh don't travel that I
mean look it's I mean he's certainly
right that it lets everybody get a
chance to go Flawless but it's not
uh
organized it's chaotic yeah and so it
gives everybody a chance but that chance
is basically just random chance right I
mean like if I were designing a game
mode my goal would be to make the to
actually design it you know what I mean
because they're not really designing
anything at this point they're just
saying here's the game mode here are the
rules and now just Ollie all the oxen
free jump in and find a way to make this
work and that to me that's
like it like what is Trials of Osiris at
this point is it just a silly mode you
do on the weekend where you just you
jump in and it's a pool party or is it
supposed to be a tournament because I
just feel like it used to have a really
strong identity
and now it's just oh my God I can't even
describe it so so let me put you in
charge let me put you in charge of uh a
destiny uh PVP
what are you doing what are the changes
that Trav wants to get
trials back to a competitive mode or a
mode that you respected is it solely
let's get the mandatory communication
back is it like what's the main thing is
it the skill based like where you at
what are the two if you're at the rank
trials for travelers
um
yeah I don't I mean again they've
already kind of left away from my vision
of what it is so that because there's
you know there if if I were making it
and I said okay well I want to make it
what I thought it should have been
before they kind of gave up on that idea
that's different than what do I think it
should be today because today it serves
kind of a different purpose but my
problem is no longer that this isn't the
trials that I fell in love with in D1
I've already kind of let that die my
problem with this that now is that uh I
don't think it serves a unique purpose
in
the destiny sandbox like it it's it's
basically indistinguishable from Iron
Banner except that it has a card that's
really it but how different is a card
from having a series of quests that you
have to complete like yeah I mean like
it's really not too different uh that
the game mode is different but the game
mode is
basically a Slayer mode and it just
doesn't change much so
um yeah uh if I were designing it I
would say I would first just pose to the
developers at Bungie and say hey what do
you want this to be and then everything
every decision I made would be around
that and I feel like they're sort of
making changes ad hoc Without Really
focusing on the bigger picture of what
what is this mode supposed to be like
what do you want what do you want the
experience to be like is it a hyper
competitive like end game activity for
PVP because if it's supposed to be that
you would have to make a very specific
series of changes that are not the
changes you're making now and if you
want it to be a tournament style weekend
tournament then you have to make changes
to support that and it feels like the
changes they've made have just sort of
been like random like they're just
trying stuff yeah and I think that was
okay back in the days when they were you
know a couple seasons ago we were
talking about this and they were just
like it was it was more than a couple
seasons ago it might have been over a
year ago when they were they were
publishing about trials every week yeah
saying like hey we're just trying this
we're trying this we're trying this back
when that was happening I felt like it
was fine because they were figuring
stuff out but now it feels like they've
decided what trials is going to look
like but they don't have a vision for
what it's supposed to be right it's the
oh it's very odd I hear what you said
the only pushback I will say is that
what it is Trials Labs right so this is
kind of an indicator that yeah they're
still experimenting but to your point it
does show that they still don't have a
clear-cut vision of what they want it to
be because if you're implementing this
in your test environment because let's
for all intensive purpose this is Trials
Labs is a test developer environment
right we're literally doing the work for
them and giving them the data they want
in this test environment so when I look
at the sentence it says we'll be testing
the new matchmaking parameters to gather
analytics and verify they work as
intended on a large scale for a
refresher and then they go into you know
how the new matchmaking work you know I
I have to give you that they don't have
that Clear Vision yet and they're still
trying to finalize what said vision is
yeah and then I'm okay with that if
they're trying to finalize it but all
I'll say is that if you trials without
card based progression
I don't really get that uh I mean it's
going to be here it'd just not be a rank
it's not being ranked as the as the
match-up thing you know you're saying
it's not being ranked at all so there's
no card based
well I mean there's card-based
progression on your ticket right it's
not tournament progression you're just
sort of playing a match and the fact
that it's get lucky seven times in a row
yeah yeah in effect
obviously your performance matters as
well but like you could you could either
be really good at the game or you could
get lucky seven times in a row like
that's crazy right right and then what
about people doing things like
connection manipulation right like I
know there's a whole bunch of people
that manipulate how their connection
connects to people and other servers so
that they get easier or harder matches
or whatever
um
I'm worried about that so I I just don't
I don't I can't explain what trials is
today I think that's a pretty bad sign
considering I've been playing Destiny
for nine years and trials was my
favorite mode for most of that it's kind
of crazy it is interesting there's
clearly been an internal decision
to let's just call it what it is to
casualize the mode right you know I I'll
be the first to admit I want to give up
to the lighthouse before at least change
and now two weeks in a row Cog went
right so clearly what I think they're
valuing is the guy like me to be like
give him a sh if they think they have a
legit shot
they will engage and oh we care about is
it the engagement at this point because
for them to make these shifts or to
suggest in a test environment these type
of shifts they want to go this route
right and it's just it is interesting
the thing that I I do struggle with the
Challenger pool though in the sense of
you know I I would like wins on ticket
to have more of a priority as opposed to
its only connection based you know I I
like the sweatiness listen to your point
try let's keep it a buck
there was a tension
when it was win six win seven you knew
you were facing another win six win
seven with it all on the line and that
sweatiness did add to the tension the
victory felt sweeter right I'm never
gonna not give you that in the old D1
environment and I'm just curious as to
why that is not prioritized in the mode
which is a seven win gold Flawless mode
so I guess that's my my curiosity there
so yeah that's interesting question yeah
and I don't have an answer for it yeah
interesting other than that uh they got
some Kilt action Bundy bungee Foundation
which is kind of pretty cool doing
things for the uh in rmhc Seattle for uh
medical treatment at the Seattle's
Children Hospital we see the Kilts
rocking they uh how they've achieved
their 77 000 goal by um
these I'll envelope get that so head
over to that donation page cash your
vote for T Bungie vote is worth ten
dollars every donation of thirty dollars
will pay for a family to stay at rmhc
Seattle for one night in addition to
helping the kids and the families
illness that are facing illness you can
check out the incentives for the fifty
dollars fifty dollar donation you get
the uh emblem that Travis mentioned the
knees out and um one Emblem Call will
all be sent to each uh 50 donor via
email and then they got more prizes and
details above so let's look at the
bungee oh yeah we have to get budget
they are always doing things in the
community and in general and I I think
that it should get employed they're one
of the more active you know companies in
terms of that I mean do you agree or do
you think there's something you kind of
see more of what other companies as well
no they're crushing it I I think Bungie
is a great company too
um support even when their games
disappoint you
know lightfall disappointed me but I'm
still no less proud to be a Bungie
supporter than ever
could be a lot worse right it could be a
great game with a crappy company wrapped
around it or yes the worst where you
have a bad game and a bad culture around
it you know OverWatch just kidding
that's I'm just messing with you I'm
messing with it shots fired I'm not
messing with you that much you're not
messing with us a little bit sus and
OverWatch I don't like so the
Dragonheart Yogi I don't know if I
missed this uh Super Chat two lots of
chat my man hashtag peace love life to
the kids IOP y'all can say we just we
hosted our piece hosted man just for
those who don't know you know uh last
word did originate here it was this was
one of the early early starts of last
word before we've been he talked and
we're like look man we gotta we gotta
get this thing to grow for a fully
Destiny crowd but it's cool to see y'all
come out and support and stuff like that
I did what I meant oh hold on oh added
come before he said watch your mouth
with the OverWatch disrespect oh he
coming at you and coming at you crazy
go ahead
you put a smoke addict he for the smoke
you know the doubt um I did want to
mention the reason that they they drew
all their characters in cartoon it's
because it's a game for kids
yeah
have fun with it though I like gaming at
it maybe he's a child oh he came for you
boy Whoa shots fires that's fine so look
we got a couple little
housekeeping notes uh it's kind of a
short 12 which is surprising
um they gotta update 7.05 which is on on
April 18th they will be um doing some
maintenance uh also we will be talking
about
um Guardian rank objective dates those
off they made some scoring updates to
the uh as far as the legend score night
fall score Grand Master score there's
still some known issues that they are
aware of
um Hawthorne is continuing to reference
uh visiting Amanda in her voice lines
that's interesting
doesn't exist anymore
yeah that's interesting yeah no doubt no
doubt so you talk about a couple other
things red borders and stuff like that
that movie of the week but um last thing
I did want to mention this was something
that he brought to my attention I know
it's a little short of show y'all but I
did want to get ease balls so shout out
to our man Mano Destra you know what I'm
saying and he had a pole up traffic this
was about the state of the destiny
community in reference to resilience
right remember when the resilience patch
I mean buff went out where Brazil
remember Bungie made that you know hey
if you have a stack of high resilience
build you'd get you know 40 percent
damage you know resilience and PVE and
people were making really strong you
know Titan builds and I remember my
warlock bill was crazy so he had a poll
up and it's literally a spit split with
1.6 000 volts and actually so excuse me
this was Castle content that had the
original poll which van Odessa our man
um also uh retweet a shout out to Castle
content now so he says was 40 percent
damage resist from a hundred resilience
too strong in PVE it's literally 50 50.
so traffic so we have a sample size of
exactly 50 50 humans you and me yes and
I'm wondering if we will be
representative let's go of the poll will
one of us say yes and one of us say no
let's see
um so we're either going to be extremely
representative or 100 or 50 percent
wrong
this will be interesting
did Bungie overtune resilience too much
they did not the problem with resilience
is that it seems like it's overpowered
because every other attribute is so crap
that's the problem and so don't touch
resilience it's fine it feels good uh
people who optimize for it but what you
should do is you should make the
decision harder because it's such an
easy decision now it's like of course
you want Max resilience of course it's
the best one by far yes but if they had
to choose between resilience and
mobility and Mobility actually did
something that would be hard that would
be hard and so Bungie has a uh a problem
with uh five
stat pulls not one of them you know what
I mean resilience is fine it's the only
one that feels good
I'm with you I'm 1 000 with you so funny
okay so we are we are unrepresentative
we are unrepresentative of the community
then we can safely assume that the 50
who said yes it is overpowered don't
know what they're talking about and are
stupid are we going we're going to go
there because this this seems to be
let's let's talk about it because this
seems to be a thing in the
I don't know I'm gonna be respectful
about words
um the hardcore
Destiny content creator community
which is Destiny is becoming too easy
they feel you know I mean this is coming
off we we had a Divinity Nerf you know
they're talking about well a Radiance
needs to be looked at you know they're
talking about a lot of game mechanics in
the game that I'm seeing the Casual
Community push back
and say hey don't listen to the streamer
so to speak you know kind of thing and
again friends with all these guys I'm
just calling how I see it based on
community reactions and things of that
nature so when these polls come up this
is kind of one of those things that I
kind of starts that that bonfire of of
um people on polarizing on the other
side look
I want to just comment first on the uh
resilience thing I'm I am with you
I think that it would it finally made
resilience matter because prior to that
it was a very high intellect build High
discipline build you know kind of focus
and I didn't really care about
resilience I mean first of all I run
warlock so I was always recovery focused
to get you know and discipline focused
to get my grenades and the great uh what
you call it a well or whatever right for
a Titan I would understand you want your
you know put up the shield I get that
you know resilience felt good having to
to spec out 100 to be a little more
tanky it did feel good but to your point
why doesn't why don't I care about
Mobility because Bungie has not made me
care about Mobility Bungie has not shown
me the value of having a high Mobility
build there's very rare scenarios where
a strength build helps me as a wall like
maybe if I'm running you know Arman car
or grass or you know I want to get
radiant a couple times but to me to
prioritize that over resilience over
getting my super I'm not gonna do it so
it's Bungie's job to your point Travis
to show me why that's attractive yo if
you do a high mobile especially Mobility
right if you do a high Mobility build
you get this you do this and I'm not I'm
not seeing that so I'm with you it's
game design now I do think it's going to
get nerfed
I think they have been because they have
their message they're scared their
message has been consistently
look at like a Shadows we work we do not
like you blazing through the content
we do not like you you could be having
fun but we don't like you blaze we want
you to be at a very the game does the
redesign I don't know if you've done the
strike trap you have to do please tell
me you've done it is if you haven't I
can't wait for you to tell me that I
know you told me about it and I was like
cool I won't do that
bro I don't know why you want me to do
it but yeah it is the most methodical
plotting you're gonna stay here at every
single section of this short thing we're
gonna add three look at Destiny one
strike where you know your ghost was
scanning something every room you went
into remember that I remember that it's
like I have to unlock this door it's got
three locks on it
yo remember with again that's the end
Destiny one was Notorious for that I
mean it it is definitely Hold Up Wait
Hold Up Wait beat this now move for like
that's actually just going from up the
hill before you go across the little
Lake into the facility the facility that
gets you to the outside where you're on
the road each of those sections is all
compartmentalized and all sectioned off
and you have to do something before you
can advance to the point where we almost
we were almost blowing up the time of 20
minutes I'm like yo and the boss
encounter is super tanky but anyway long
and short of it is they have shown
consistently they do not like us
pleasing through the content and they're
gonna put stop caps there and and that's
what my concern is but back to the
original question for you if you don't
want people though that you don't want
people to run resilience
I mean how hard is it to make the other
perks matter I also think you should get
something extra for getting to 100. I do
I think that if you get to 100 on you
know grenades you should get an extra
grenades if you have 100 discipline I
think if you get uh 100 on intellect
your roaming super should last like 25
longer and you're you're one and done
super should do like 25 more damage or
something like that I think that if you
have 100 Mobility you should get what's
that uh Arc effect where you get to run
faster you get something like that if
you have 100 Mobility because people
would go crazy that's a good call
um
Bungie call me I'm full of these bro
he's ready this is just top of my head
I'm ready he's ready to build crafting
this is build crafting you make it so
that when you get to 100 and you have to
choose three right and then it's and
then you have a bidding war then you've
got all these different builds where
people like oh the three I've got or
Mobility so I can go faster and an extra
grenade and just do that sort of stuff
and you know it will require some
reworking of the sandbox of course but
my thinking is that if if you're really
so scared of resilience maybe make the
others interesting honestly if you if
you nerfed they first of all resilience
already got nerfed yes if you Nerf it
again I will still stick with it because
all the other ones are so bad you're
gonna give me some reason to build crap
that's all I'm asking you're right I you
nailed it bro one of the best feelings
on off 3.0 is being Amplified and I'm
moving when you know it's fun to watch
someone who's also in the stairs because
you see the little blue trailer steps
and you know he's moving fast and it
feels good like it that Inc remember the
encounter y'all hate I love it Osiris
one with the Rocky music that y'all
laugh y'all say it's Cody
play that at ARC 3.0 moving bro it is so
easy I was like oh my God like Hawk is
like Unfortunately they force you to
play it in in strand yeah hopefully to
make you change but yeah you could you
could switch out I mean after like you
beat the whole thing but like bro like
it's so crazy to me like how that could
something as simple as that could change
the way you feel about a stat you know
kind of thing and that to me is is
really cool Triple Ice turret warlock
Travis is high in his game director
Shenanigans nice suggestion yeah yeah
man I agree I agree I think I don't want
to be game director I want to be game uh
complainer because I feel like every
every development Studio should just
have like a really like picky Jew and it
just sort of like comes out and goes you
know what really bothers me about with
the voice not the voice yeah they should
just be able to come out and just do
that I want to be that can I get hired
as Dad thank you
he did it later in the Stream you really
I'm thinking about the people who don't
have time in the day okay
I just want to be that guy and just come
out
you that I can't with you
when you put it up he did it at a hour
in you're fine you should be okay from
The Divided station we should be good
why is that gonna get you demonetized
this is my culture we here at the last
word love all cultures do not objectify
anyone see I see it
no we're all good bro like I I think
it's great I think that that's the way
to go you know it does feel like this uh
Nerf is coming so we'll see how they
handle the rest of them but um yeah
actually kind of a short week unusually
I thought it was gonna be more than it's
12 to be honest I was like kind of Blaze
dude that's mid-season yeah mid-season
little twab joint kind of going on you
know grand mass I guess the last
question I got for you before we kind of
rap was uh will you be because remember
they said that the the point of entry
for Grand Masters will be lower right
yep so you know will you attempt it now
especially double rewards week you know
see how that is at any point I think
it's the um the kylo strike right now
the one with when you enter her ship the
right of proving you gotta fight that
dude at the end he's got all the
fireballs and all the chaotic this would
you be jumping in there
yeah actually yes I know you weren't
expecting that answer I wasn't expecting
that the two things the two things that
I hate are sort of going away one is the
grind to just do the activity absolutely
hate that and then two is what was the
second thing I was complaining about the
uh Champions is it oh yeah thank you
Champions are now not as annoying they
don't control your Loadout for you right
so you can play the game however you
want
um and the reason I'm going to play them
is because For the first time in a long
time
I actually need to send the material oh
you broke I'm finally running out yeah I
don't really upgrade that much but I've
been playing more Destiny this uh past
year than I have uh for a while I think
I said Shadow keep I kind of you know I
just doing a lot of reviews got a lot of
stuff going on but I have been putting
more time into it
um so I actually kind of need some of
the Senate materials I'm not broke but
uh so you wasn't anyone that you wasn't
in on The Duality form when it was going
down bruh no I saw people talking about
it but I was in the middle of something
I can't remember what I was I was doing
something that was taking all my time
and I couldn't get in there fair enough
I think I have five what's the
ascendants the golf balls yeah what's
cool is I really broke on the
enhancement course because I use the
upgrade modules way too much I'll buy
them from Banshee so this is a good week
now that I jumped I was just doing
regular nightfalls and I was just like
raking in I went from like 10 to 40 and
I'm like oh okay so they're giving us
double every run kind of thing so it's a
good source for that I'm still mad at
Bungie you don't give us a good source
yeah I mean I guess you do the bounties
from Banshee you get a Core I just wish
there was an additional source for that
as well as the um the crafting material
one the alloy one I always want a little
bit more but um yeah man I I was
surprised at your answer that's cool but
uh that's all I got for this uh last
this week at Bungie you know what I'm
saying shout out to e for letting uh the
the inmates from the assignment so much
more like
enjoyable and
brief it feels like there's a lot less
bloat you know oh don't do that too my
boy
we love you e and I miss you I don't
like hosting anymore I'm just trying to
get uh him to kick me off the show
there's an advantage showing up looking
good and talking and talking smack and
you you gotta worry about nothing that I
don't miss any of this anxiety of
setting up shows and doing a lot of
stuff yeah yeah I don't miss it bro by
the way congratulations man now that
we're wrapping up the show we're about
to talk about what we're doing I know
one of the things you're doing this week
is you have episode 300 of aisle yes yes
as somebody who produced an episode 300
of a beloved show let me tell you
congratulations sir I know how hard that
is even though I was only there for like
the last 50 episodes and I took all the
credit and glory for the three
for all 300 episodes so good for you sir
yes and um I hope it goes well and I'm
gonna try to pop in I appreciate you
brother yeah it means a lot it means a
lot we've been doing it a long time you
know obviously last word the original
story was Flashpoint here before so it
definitely started here we were Destiny
only for first I allowed the whole name
it's based off Destiny so I oh I
literally old Bungie I don't know if
everybody come for me like but they
always show love but um yeah man this
this is this I'm gonna make sure they're
lawyers here
[Laughter]
you're gonna become like IGN the acronym
that doesn't stand for anything it
doesn't stand for anything legally we're
not allowed to say what it stands for
anymore so now it's just ilp.com I got
my contingencies if they come if they
right that's great yeah that's it but it
could also call each other the log
right they love pocket I can't I
unlocked loads of gaming right oh lock
that yeah yeah okay yeah yeah we can
switch it you could you could go iron
log
[Laughter]
it's a big one and I'm looking to
celebrate it with the community try to
do some special things appreciate you
trying yeah I'm gonna miss you man I
really wanted to go but I know you're on
vacation I know I know but I was hoping
I'd get a little pop in you know what
I'm saying a little pie you popped in
today I mean I'm saying a little popping
I was cheated was part of History you
know what I'm saying but anyway now shot
the attic in the chat shout out to
everybody that pulled up it's gonna be
fun it's gonna be fun we're gonna
celebrate obviously we can't celebrate
too long because there's actually a lot
of news this week so we will cover that
but um yeah that's all I got as far as
um Duke look be on the lookout contents
up about the whole redfall Fiasco what's
going on with that we got more content
coming more game reviews on um
lordsgaming.net check that out citizen
said Iron log after dark I can't uh we
got that but uh what you got going on
what's the next uh big things that you
can talk about yeah the only big thing I
can talk about immediately is
um the Dead Island to review Tuesday
um and then I've got some previews
coming up that I can't talk about and
then I've got uh
something else that's pretty big that
I'll be announcing uh April 19 or April
20. so
um oh it's April 19th it is for sure uh
so yeah I've got some cool stuff coming
up um and then uh yeah we've got bitcast
on Sundays yes tutor at Thai Guy Travis
and um
also I'm doing a destiny guide on what
you can play free to play so as this is
a destiny podcast uh probably next week
sometime that will be live and I plan on
keeping my free account now that I went
through the trouble of making one uh
which by the way is kind of hard like
you need like a cell phone number
it was like kind of annoying
um but now that I've got a fully active
uh haven't spent a dollar on any content
account I'm going to keep that one
pristine and I'm going to update every
uh season the stuff that they add or
take away from free to play because I
found out there's quite a bit of stuff
that they you know they made like an
arbalest Mission yes a quest where you
get an arborist and I didn't realize
you can't accept that Quest from shahan
unless you own lightfall
stop
yeah
so it's like an old gun that they put
behind a new paywall which is kind of
interesting so I didn't know that um
yeah there's a bunch of interesting
stuff I didn't know about the XP system
to unlock planets really
you can't go to three or four of the
planets and it's locked behind you
getting account XP really yeah so like I
can't go to the dreaming City because I
don't have enough account to XP I didn't
know that that's interesting yeah no
there's a dude there's all this
interesting stuff I feel like I'm seeing
Destiny through the fresh eyes it's very
weird it's very very odd but yeah I've
been playing a lot of it today yeah the
only change I saw was the subclass
you know because remember we used to
have all these convoluted convoluted
ways to get subclass but we had to go to
the dreaming City and do blyde well and
do all these things and make myself the
drop and I remember those days but now
it's kind of like hey if you want void
get a void weapon or you know and just
create orbs and then get XP
and then talk to I Cora and buy it I was
just like oh okay I also had no idea you
can't access Nightfall at all if you're
free to play
um
which is crazy it won't even let me like
touch the icons yeah they they are maybe
because I thought I thought it was just
when the certain strikes were acted
it's weird but isn't this week what is
this Nightfall this week the Nightfall
is the proverb ground one wait what
title yeah so that shouldn't that be
that's a good one says I have to own the
lightfall it doesn't even say like
Beyond lighter or whatever wow they're
tired yeah that's a cool playlist
activity I know it's crazy all I can
click on is the big strikes icon I can't
click on any of the other stuff so yeah
like I'm saying I'm kind of going
through this so I'm going to uh post
that it probably will not help literally
anybody that watches this show because
if you watch the show you're not a
free-to-play player but if you have a
friend that's thinking about getting
into it hopefully it will be useful yes
and the reason they're having me write
it is because apparently with a lot of
people Google search for it really so oh
SEO oh it's an SEO type of thing they
were like hey we they were like Travis
could you write about this and I was
like totally why why yeah like they're
like because a lot of people search for
it and apparently there's not a lot of
good answers out there so and I'll do it
and it shows that they were popping off
with the light fall engagement numbers
so again although yeah popping off with
people that didn't want to pay for it
apparently yeah sure what can I think
without paying for it honestly here's
what my theory is which theory is what
you think is going on that because the
last expansions were on gamepad yes that
it's a lot of people going wait I can't
just play the game with Game Pass now
and they're probably Googling like okay
well what can I play that's my guess I
don't know though that's a good point
back for Dead starting trouble well I
gotta ask you wonder if it's the Sony
influence trap
doubt it okay and then I think I think
them not being on uh Game Pass is
definitely the sunny influence but I
think them locking up uh how many people
have access to it
it's probably a profitability thing and
I'm sure they'll be on Playstation
whatever at some point I believe
PlayStation has Beyond light in PS what
are those PS Services PS plus PS yeah
interesting yeah I think I think they
definitely I'm sure that was the first
thing Sony said was like yeah of course
you can play it on Xbox but not not
gameplay
oh hell yeah that verbiage there's no
doubt that was in that contract yeah you
are not doing that I agree you're never
gonna make that mistake again absolutely
we go wrap up nice little brief show you
know say go send some love to e and all
of that you know what I'm saying we're
just holding them down during a vacation
we will be back to normal When the boxes
Channel most likely next week guest and
all that good stuff but shout out to my
man Travis full episodes everybody in
the room for pulling up even the
non-destiny heads up see it in here
which is kind of cool last minute attic
thank you for the support and everything
else but that's all I got anything else
before we get up out of here a tram I
love you and I want to kiss you on the
lips oh maybe later get me some drinks
first please before we get to the market
yeah he said Margarita is the secret I
know your favorite yeah your wife know I
love those I might drink yellow if any
of you guys do want to get uh Cog drunk
I can tell you he favors large
margaritas with extra salt yes yes yes
yes yes he likes the extra salt yes he
makes his business and pleasure get that
extra salt we was doing so good we was
doing so good to the end to the end
[Laughter]
and on that note we are out of here
everybody enjoy and this is
the last word the last word